(upbeat Italian-style music)
- That's crazy.
- So we just heard about this
place here in Philadelphia
that sells pizza flavored ice cream.
The shop posted a photo on
Instagram of a scoop of the
ice cream on a slice of pizza.
Instagram went crazy.
I figured I have to check this out.
Philadelphia's far,
and I don't have a car.
- Come on, let's go!
(electronic music)
Hello Philly.
- Alright, so we are just
short of Philadelphia now.
We're heading to Little Baby's Ice Cream
where the have a pizza flavored ice cream
that you can get on top
of a slice of pizza.
- [Rob] The garlic scares me.
That's an ingredient in ice
cream that I'm not quite sure--
- [Christian] I bet they
put some thought into this.
(electronic music)
Alright, so we're not exactly sure
what we're doing at the moment.
- Here we go.
- You see it?
- It's up here on the left.
(Italian-style folk music)
- We're about to try their
pizza flavored ice cream.
- So tomato paste ice
cream, oregano, garlic--
- And just deliciousness.
There's a pizza place
that's literally connected
to Little Baby's Ice Cream,
so not only are we gonna have
some of their pizza flavored ice cream,
we're also gonna have that
on top of a slice of pizza.
This is definitely one
of the stranger items
that I've eaten.
- It smells fantastic.
- Yeah, I mean, well, it's pizza.
- I mean, that definitely
tastes like pizza.
- Oh my god, it's crazy!
- That is incredible how
much that tastes like pizza.
- It's so good!
- I definitely wouldn't want
any sort of sprinkles on this.
- Sprinkled with red pepper flakes.
- Yeah, red pepper flakes, maybe. (laughs)
I would not expect that to
taste as good as it tastes.
- I love the hot and the cold together.
Can you imagine if they did,
like, a pizza waffle cone
and put this ice cream in it?
- Hmm.
- (makes exploding noise)
- A bit drippy.
- It gets to be a little messy.
It's a little bit of a challenge
to experience the good things in life.
- And that's frozen cheese.
This place has been serving
this pizza for a while.
Just this week is when they
decided to blow up on Instagram.
- Yeah, they said it's been six years.
- This pizza slice is actually solid.
This is a good piece of pizza.
And the ice cream is also pretty good.
I don't think you do any favors to either
by eating them together.
So I wanna point out that we
are two native New Yorkers
who left New York for
Philadelphia to eat pizza.
- Shh.
- Pizza is quintessential to New York,
but Philly has something
else going for it.
(jazzy music)
- Oh yeah.
- Philadelphia.
- Bye, Philadelphia.
- Who in New York has a car?
Just this guy, the only
guy that has a car.
That's not why I asked you here, though.
- [Rob] Yes, it is.
- [Christian] Yeah, it is.
It's 100 percent why I asked
you here, now let's go.
(squeaking)